[Music]
well hello this is outnumbered I'm
Harris Faulkner here with my co-host
Emily compagno also joining us today
Martha McCallum Mercedes schlapp and
Mark Thiessen is here oh it's gonna rock
Biden is now enroute to Arizona oh great
he'll go to the border right
no
he will be about an hour away from the
border but he won't be visiting it
despite the unprecedented crisis there
that we all know that we're facing more
than 2 million people two and a half
actually have crossed the border
illegally in just the past fiscal year
and we've learned of hundreds
of people dying in the waters that you
see there that's the Rio Grande
and a record number of children arriving
at the border who are alone unattended
and Lord only knows what's happened to
them along the way
in just the past three days there have
been 14
000 encounters at the border and we call
them that because they're not really
going through the checkpoints they're
just kind of flowing over
this is the thermal imaging from Fox
news's bill malusion of people crossing
into Texas last week and right now
border agents are bracing for a massive
influx the Biden Administration is
reportedly projecting daily border
crossings could double when the Trump
era border policy known as title 42 ends
on December 21st
apparently the president does not think
all of this is important and how do we
know because he said it
because they're more important than
going on they're going to invest
billions of dollars in a new Enterprise
important to whom Mark Thiessen well
that would be a more defensible answer
if he had gone to the border at any
other time in the first two years of his
presidency which he hasn't done
um we've got you know when he says that
this is not important we've had we've
had one million gotaways 4 million uh
encounters at the border so some people
cost more than one so it's but roughly
five million that's a good point people
uh crossing our border we've got
fentanyl pouring in over over the border
which is causing Untold debts in this
country it's fueling crime because a lot
of the crime spike in cities like the
New York and other places far away from
the border it's drug-related crime so
this isn't important to the president of
the United States that's just a shocking
statement you know what that point that
you were making that people cross more
than once even when our border patrol
and protection tries to send people back
there is no deterrent in coming right
back the good news though the Silver
Lining is if they commit a crime and
they get sent back when they try to come
back in that gives us a little T if we
can see them and find them and they're
not working their way around things
because they know they want to come back
unless they're a god away which is which
is the reason of those so and and also
what the cartels do is they take they
they send surges of people of migrants
in one part of the border so they can
move the fentanyl in another that's
what's happening
Emily that's right you know I can't
imagine what is more callous what's more
disheartening than having your
commander-in-chief stand there with an
umbrella obscurion half his face and
saying your lives are not important to
me but that's exactly the message that
President Biden was sending and that's
why the president of the border patrol
uh came out and said exactly that
nothing is more important than the
Safety and Security of the American
people but to President Biden it's an
afterthought and the union weighed into
as well today visiting an ice cream shop
very important they said visiting our
border where illegal immigration deaths
escapes and Fentanyl smuggling set new
records non-stop thousands dying as a
result not important they say no
surprise that Biden doesn't think it's
important or worthy of visiting or
bringing attention to
to him it's a win-win what is so
frightening and aberrant to me even more
so than that is the fact that in
November three different border patrol
agents took their own lives setting a
record for that for the border patrol
and just I want to say this weekend the
body of a 22 year old specialist Army
National Guard Bishop Evans was
recovered he died trying to save two
migrants lives there in the river so his
funeral will be coming up and I just
can't imagine again the message from
your boss the commander-in-chief of the
United States saying to everyone
essentially your lives do not matter
their Bishop Evans as we just showed his
photo right there we're used to hearing
the messaging though because secretary
mayorkas when I was down at the Border
in September has you know really not
installed any kind of confidence in
these men and women to be able to handle
the truth and that this situation is not
going to change I mean can you imagine
if your job is to protect the border and
you see as many as five million crossers
since the beginning of this
Administration uh Crossing illegally and
you're told basically that the border is
closed
and you're watching what is happening I
mean I anybody who's watched any of this
video knows that that is a Lie the
border is not closed the border is
immensely porous incredibly dangerous
people are losing their lives and what
what do they get scolded right when
they're being accused of whipping people
even though the photographer who took
the photo and was there said you know it
might look like that but that's actually
not what was happening so they are being
grossly mistreated the people who are
protecting our border what about if
you're a parent of a child who died of a
fentanyl overdose and tragically there
are more and more of those parents in
this country every day and this is how
it is getting across so for the
president not to go that you know what
he also he has a lot of leeway right now
he's in a very strong position what if
the president what if President Biden
said you know what I'm going to the
Border I'm going to bring a couple
Republicans couple Democrats you guys
because they she said you know
Republicans won't do anything yeah
so it would but maybe he has that
opportunity now in a way that he hasn't
before and people in America want the
border secure Republicans and Democrats
poll after poll after poll go for it
make it happen yeah but but he says that
that's not as important and look the
Taiwanese chip company that's up in
Phoenix that he's going to visit that's
important yes absolutely but we can
prioritize we do that as parents every
day not everything is an emergency this
actually at the border is an emergency
well there's something called
multitasking
and actually do and it's something that
when I worked in the in the Trump
Administration the president was working
on securing the border that was
definitely a priority working with our
border patrol agents as well in addition
to dealing with the economy dealing with
global threats so to say that this is
that there are more important issues for
this president to make that comment is a
complete insult to the American people
and that literally trickles down to the
administration where you have secretary
Alejandro Mallorca yes to even deal with
the Border crisis uh even give the
support needed to our border patrol
officers and so in essence it's why
you're going to see this Republican
House Majority move forward with
investigations on secretary majorca's
and bring to light the tragedy that
we're seeing at the border well and look
at what Republican Tom Tillis is doing
right now working with Kirsten Cinema
again this is going on in the state of
Arizona now that's where she is and and
the president could be there and but we
I think we know what we think about him
with her well and she gets chased into a
ladies room by men and the President
says well that's just the way things go
and in politics well and Katie Hobbs who
certified her own election but that's a
whole different story she actually has
talked about the border and saying that
they have an issue that we're having
here in Arizona so for the president to
ignore even Democrats on this issue I
think that it makes him very vulnerable
and you're going to need more of these
Democrats yeah yeah let's get to this
the White House Press Secretary Kareem
Jean-Pierre the only French I know went
after Republicans for their stunts when
questioned On the Border watch
if the president is not going to make
time to visit her during his trip to
tomorrow during his trip tomorrow to a
border state
will he do it in in New Year
look I addressed this last week about
the President visiting the Border I'm
not going to go beyond what I just laid
out we believe the question again is I
was just answering to your colleague in
the back is that what are congressional
Republicans going to do to actually deal
with this issue instead of doing
political stunts
okay let's talk about that
it's not political stunts it's a real
crisis and here's the here's the thing
that Biden doesn't understand his
failure to secure the border is is bad
for the country but it's also bad for
him and his agenda so he wants to pass
immigration reform in Congress right he
wants to either you mentioned Tillis and
Cinema have come up with a bill that
would that would extend title 42 that
would do something for the dreamers we
also need to change our immigration
system because we need legal immigrants
coming into this country we have 10
million unfilled jobs in this country we
have a labor shortage that's historic
right well nobody says that legal
immigration is the problem you can't
that's not the problem no it's not we
need them but but this border crisis is
an obstacle to expanding legal
immigration because you cannot the
prerequisite for immigration reform is a
secure border all right real quickly
Martha when you come up with that Cinema
and Tom Tillis that bipartisan review of
this and a bill coming we know that
Republicans out there many of them don't
want amnesty at all so is that something
they can can get off the bill there or
do you think they meet I think the
American people are so frustrated that
there is no middle ground because they
know there is Middle Ground on this
issue we have jobs that need to be
filled in this country and you have a
lot of common ground Maggie Hassan went
to the Border too who was reelected
Senate Senator New Hampshire so you know
I think there's an opportunity here and
I think it's very sad and and cheap
political sort of banter to not actually
do I don't know why the president
wouldn't want to get in on this and it's
happening well I think it's really
important to understand this immigration
negotiations have been happening from
one Administration to the next it's true
now here's the deal Republicans have
agreed to even some DACA uh you know
allowing for citizenship or some sort of
DACA negotiation that is a place that
they can maybe find comments you think
that stays on involved it could the
border security problem is the biggest
issue where you cannot move the
Democrats and they do not want to fund
border security is it about constituency
is that is that too far to go well
remember
Kamala Harris ran on fixing the
immigration system two years later the
waiting list for legal immigration
before a judge to see a judge remember
it's still over two years so even the
Democrats did as well but clearly they
don't care about I'm glad you reminded
us and I actually ran on because she
didn't get one delegate exactly and it's
important for me to clarify as well that
the um that Bishop Evans who died saving
those two migrants that was earlier this
year in April I think when you go to the
Border in Eagle Pass you can see the
memorial that's there on the Riverside
for him it's really beautiful there have
been many children who have that young
man who've lost their lives and our men
and women jump in that River to go save
them hey everyone I'm Emily compagno
catch me and my co-host Harris Faulkner
and Kaylee mcineny on outnumbered every
weekday at 12 p.m Eastern or sets your
DVR also don't forget to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights